et quand on est allé s'exprimer à
l'assemblée nationale avec présent des
régions de france les présidents des
départements et des maires de france
nous avons réalisé à quel point la rs
était bloquée par un conseil
scientifique pas un ministère de la
santé qui était qui n'a jamais suivre
lui dans la doctrine
aujourd'hui on nous parle de lits
supplémentaires mais on n'a pas de
formation de médecins à côté on nous
parle de la vaccination depuis deux mois
d'octobre on demande quand même les
tests salivaires
on les a pas eu la validation qui a été
fait par les européens sur l'état des
autotests et c'est là ce que je demande
depuis quand le président de la
république on se retourne ça fait plus
d'un mois que la chasse à damas mais
l'autorisation pour le faire alors que
d'autres pays le font depuis moins de
dix ans n'avait quant à chaque fois
entre trois à quatre mois de retard son
tour de décision d autres horizons mais
en fait on peut dire peut-être aussi
qu'ils ont trois quatre mois de retard
systématiquement comme mais protocole cd
auto test salivaire qui donnerait donc
le résultat au bout de dix minutes
oui sauf que le ministère de la santé
dit non c'est pas vrai il marche non
mais puisqu'il vient d autoriser
maintenant le président de la république
en a parlé en octobre ils ont été
validés il ya plus d'un mois le loot la
chasse à haute autorité de santé
viennent de le donner l'accord et ils
sont en pharmacie depuis samedi donc je
peux peut-être quand même en acheter les
mettre à disposition des gens qui
veulent en terrasse
spectacle pour les autos tester et le
pays ou la région pour faire en sorte
que mes spectacles de plein air puisse
ouvrir que la région est prête à les
payer à les financer cette action avait
commandé 500 1000 g par le droit j'en ai
commandé 500 me ces cinq millions
d'habitants jargon des 500 mais j'ai pas
le droit ok on m'a expliqué que ce n'est
pas encore prêt ils sont fiables à 95 %
95 % c'est plus que beaucoup de que
l'antigène icain que par rapport au pc
et donc on se retourne dans un schéma où
et bien vous dis non
après que ce que je vous disais moi je
suis je suis contre l'adhésion bessens
ministère de la santé il vous a dit non
je vous réponds pas en fait hein mais
vraiment pas donc ne vous traite par le
mépris